EVAN JONES: Good
morning, everybody.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir.
These are your live
webinars that we're
hosting every single Tuesday
for the month of February.
I'm your host, Evan
Jones, and today we're
going to be talking about
what can you build with Google
Cloud in 10 minutes or less.
So first give me a little bit
of background about myself
and also our team
behind the scenes
here to answer your questions
any time during the session
here.
So I'm a technical curriculum
developer on the Google Cloud
team.
And I specialize in building
data and machine learning
courses.
I'm extremely excited to
be here with you all today
to give you a sense of what
you can do on Google Cloud,
but behind the scenes we also
have a team of a moderation
panel--
Barry, one of my
good friends, who's
going to help answering
your questions
live that you can post any
time during this session right
below this window.
So let's talk a
little bit about what
we're going be learning today.
So first up I'm going to give
you about a 15-minute lecture
in what we're going to be doing
for the Google Cloud Platform.
Specifically, we're going to
be spinning up a VM instance
and launching a web server,
hopefully with under 10 minutes
to spare, so you all watching
can keep me accountable.
And we're also going to be
doing a live question and answer
session at the end,
but that doesn't
mean you have whole
of your best questions
until the end of the webinar.
Feel free to type them
live, so we can answer it
anytime by our moderation team.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
Ultimately, I'm here to help
you start out your Google Cloud
journey today.
So if you never heard
of Google Cloud--
or you've heard of
Cloud technologies,
but you haven't really a
chance to get experience with
launching a virtual machine--
or you've heard a lot
of these acronyms,
and you don't know
where to start--
you're exactly in
the right place.
So today what we're
going be doing
is three different things.
We're going to set up, in
your interactive Qwiklabs
environment, a virtual machine
that's going be launching a web
server, and again
we're going to shoot
that in the audacious goal
of 10 minutes or less.
And then what you
can do later on
is-- this is just
going to be one lab.
I like to called it
the tip of the iceberg.
There's going to be seven labs
in what we call the Google
Cloud Platform
Essentials Quest, which
is just a series of different
labs in our lab environment
platform.
So later on today
or tomorrow we're
going to give you
free credits, so you
can check out the rest of
the labs at your leisure.
So this is just to continue
your training at your own pace.
And after that if you really get
enthused, and we hope you will,
you can also take more training.
And if you want to hear the
sounds of my voice and my other
training compatriots
here, you can go
to cloud.google.com/training and
take some more on-demand online
courses through Coursera or sign
up for a local course as well,
but let's get started.
So as I mentioned, our primary
goal today, I don't really
like to do a lot
of talking, so I'd
like to give you a interactive
live demo of exactly what we're
going to be doing.
And you can follow along
in the labs environment
that we're be showing you soon.
So ultimate end goal--
we want to spin up a web server
on a virtual machine box--
10 minutes or less.
Let's see if we can't do it.
Get ready to follow along.
So if there's any slide that I
want you to pay attention to,
it's this one.
So in the chat below you're
going to have this link
as well, but if you don't,
type in your browser now,
goog.gl/PbvwPL, making
sure to note the capitals.
And this is how you're going
to get 20 free lab credits just
for showing up today, so
this will start you off
on our labs environment
inside of Qwiklabs.
And all of our sandbox student
accounts and instructions
for these labs are hosted
within this platform,
so I'm going to leave that
up there for just a few
more seconds while you take that
down or click on it from below.
Once you're there, I want
you to browse the quests, so
in the upper left hand corner--
if you're not already there--
that little rectangle with
a bunch of other squares
inside of it, that's your
lab catalog for Qwiklabs.
Click on that, then
click on quests,
and then find the one
marked GCP Essentials.
So as you noticed, there's
a ton of different tracks
that you could take for these
quests, so if interested
in data and machine
learning or a bunch
of these other different topics
that are there like Kubernetes
for example or ML APIs--
well, those are a little
bit more advanced.
We're going to start out with
the bare-bones basics, which
is setting up Google
Compute Engine to process
things in a virtual machine.
Click on GCP Essentials.
Now in order to redeem those
20 free credits, and these
are lab credits, click
on Enroll in this Quest.
And a quest, again, is
just a collection of--
in this particular case--
seven different labs.
And in today's
session, we'll just
be going through that first
one, which is creating your very
first virtual machine.
So enroll in the quest.
Click on the Creating
Virtual Machine Lab.
You'll be prompted with
this modal that says,
lab access costs
one credit, and you
should see something that says
if he went through that link,
and you enrolled in that, that
you have 20 credits available.
Go ahead and spend
one of those credits
to launch this particular lab.
Now I'll ask you not
to start the lab yet,
because we're going be doing
it together a little bit later.
But if you're having any
technical issues whatsoever
in getting to this
page, ultimately it
will look like this with that
green Start Lab button just
aching to be pressed.
If you can't get to this
page, be sure to type
into the chap below, and
we have Jade and Barry here
to help you out from the
Qwiklab side and our side
at Google to help you out.
Pause on that page, because
that's your lab instructions
that we're going be
going through together.
And a little bit about
the Qwiklabs environment--
why we're asking you to log into
our Qwiklabs instead of using
your own Google Cloud
Platform account--
if you don't have a Google
Cloud Platform account,
or if you didn't want to use
your own personal account,
these are free sandbox
accounts with these credits
that we've given you.
And what happens, it
will automatically
create this email address
and password for you,
and then it will open
up the console for you
for a predetermined
period of time.
In this particular case, the
lab is live for 30 minutes.
So one of the things
they'll ask you to do--
all the way on the
Don't side there is--
if and when you
do start the lab,
don't click End Lab prematurely,
because that will shut down
all of your resources as well.
And we'll go through this
when we actually go to the lab
together, but in one
tab in your browser just
be sure that you have
that open as well.
OK, I promised
you that I'm going
to be of very short
lecturer, so we
have about five minutes of
topics to cover on the Cloud
in general.
And then we're going to jump
into doing this lab together,
and you guys can time
to see if we can do it
in 10 minutes or less.
All right, one of
my favorite topics
to talk about-- before
my career here at Google,
I was a freelance web
designer and web developer,
and I ended up wearing
a ton of different hats.
So although I really
like to work, and make
these beautiful
graphics and images,
and design a beautiful
UI for the site,
ultimately it came time to
answer the question of where
am I going to host this?
Where am I going
to store this data?
If folks are uploading
things to my site,
where are those ultimately
going to get stored?
So in addition to
having a design hat
on-- or if you're writing
software programs,
having your programming head on,
which is what you really want
to focus on--
back in the day, you
also had to be almost
like a hardware engineer or
an infrastructure engineer
just to make sure that you
had enough storage for all
the things that you're
looking to store and serve.
You had enough compute power if
you're running a lot of compute
and computational jobs--
or if you just had any kind
of computations for
your applications,
you needed to make sure that
you had a big enough server--
a CPU to process that--
also for latency-- if you
have enough networking.
And last but not least, if a
server disk fails, or there is
an operating system update
that needs to be installed,
you also need to be kind of
a DBA or an infrastructure
technician to make sure
that all of your hardware
is running smoothly.
So you wore many of
these different hats,
and we all know jack of
all trades, master of none.
It's not in your best interest
to be focused on infrastructure
when, ultimately, you want to be
focused on building the latest
and greatest business
software-- whatever
it is that your business
is looking to do.
So what happened in
the last 10 years?
So back when I was
building web sites,
I had to buy or rent
out a box server, that's
sitting in my closet somewhere,
to ultimately set up these web
pages, and I have to go
on and manually install
software updates and
operating system updates.
Where has that space gone?
So all on the way
on the left you
see there is the data
center, where I'm
managing all this stuff myself.
We call it on-premise,
or physical,
or you're co-located there.
And eventually it
moved into, well,
everyone else is having
the same problem.
We all don't want
to buy these boxes.
And even if we're perfectly
good at maintaining them,
and we're experts at hardware,
a lot of times the machines
are sitting unused.
And we're still paying
for electricity costs
even when the demand
on, say, our website
isn't that high until
Black Friday comes along,
and then coincidentally we don't
have enough server capacity.
So it's hard to manage the
ups and downs when we just
have a static
amount of hardware,
so what that
generally shifted to
was a virtualization
environment, where
we could rent out time
in these machines.
But you would still be
responsible for installing,
and managing, and dealing with
all the maintenance headaches
that went therein as well.
So what has ultimately happened
with this big push to Cloud?
So all the way on the right,
you see that the catchphrase
is that it's serverless.
It's fully automated, so unless
you really liked managing that
hardware yourself, which a lot
of people didn't-- they really
wanted to focus on
their core competency,
which is building
amazing software models,
designing incredible web site
and application experiences--
you no longer need to
worry about infrastructure.
It's fully managed.
And in the example that I
gave, where Black Friday you
might not have enough
servers, and then
if there is a slow
Monday or Tuesday
you have way too much capacity.
So you are wasting time, and
you have the opportunity cost
in servers sitting there.
You want this more of an elastic
scalable when you need it,
and it scales down
when you don't.
And that's exactly where Google
Cloud Platform comes into play.
So Google Cloud Platform--
I like to say
Google's been doing
Cloud for more than 10
years, but you've just
heard of it recently.
That's because Google has been
running its own private Cloud,
because it ultimately had to
solve the exact same problems
that you've had
to solve, which is
if you're going to be organizing
all the world's information
and making it accessible to
everybody around the world,
Google had to solve this
hardware problem for itself.
And so, they invested millions
of dollars in infrastructure,
and building these
undersea cables
that you see here
for networking,
and these data centers
all around the world,
including Edge locations to make
sure that Google's web pages
and search queries can
be accessed anywhere
throughout the world.
So as they like to say,
don't reinvent the wheel.
If Google's already got the
infrastructure in place,
and it's good enough for things
like Gmail, Google Photos,
and any of the other
Google applications
in answering your
search queries,
it's going to be good enough
for your applications as well.
So this is ultimately
what makes Google Google.
And only recently in
the last five years
or so, Google has made that
hardware, that infrastructure,
available to you all for your
use in what's called the Google
Cloud Platform.
So say I've convinced
you on Cloud,
you might be faced with a lot
of different product choices
or icons, and you might
not be sure where to start.
So OK, I've got the idea
that it's a platform,
but I don't really know--
should I be using App Engine?
Should I be using my-- do
I have a big data need?
I need a diagram or
some kind of training
to figure out where
I should start.
And you know that the
cloud in and of itself
is elastic and scalable,
but the key word
that I want you to focus on for
today is that it's a platform.
It can be anything
that you want it to be,
so the key three
areas of the Cloud--
Compute, doing a lot
of computational power,
so that you're running
a bunch of scripts,
or you're serving up
your applications,
or you're performing
a lot of computation.
Data and analytics,
that's my specialty.
So if you are running analysis
over petabytes of data,
and you want it to be done
at a blazing fast speed,
and you don't want to
worry about the size
of your hard drive
limiting the amount of data
that you can store, the platform
can be used for that as well--
or if you wanted to get
into machine learning.
And last but not
least, if you wanted
to not worry about
load balancing
or any of these other
typical headaches
that comes with running
an entire infrastructure
enterprise, Google
Cloud Platform
provides those products
options for you there as well.
But since this is our
first foray into this,
we're going to focus on one of
the very fundamental building
blocks.
I would say there's two.
The first one is
compute, which is
what we're going to be spinning
up with our virtual machine
today, and then in future
sessions and webinars
you're going to learn
about Google Cloud Storage
where you can actually
store a lot of that data.
So let's start our journey.
So I promised I wouldn't talk
for too long without showing
you an amazing
demo, so let's jump
into our lab which is Creating
a Virtual Machine on GCP
in Google Cloud Platform.
And we're going to put a
web server software, NGINX,
on that box in 10
minutes or less.
So I'll ask you to do is--
right now you should
have Qwiklabs.
You've already navigated to
GCP Essentials down here.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about these labs,
and what you can do after this.
And in here you'll see the
seven labs that are part of this
series, so if you're already
getting excited for things
like, oh, man we're going to
be doing Kubernetes and stack
drivers-- you can see
on my shirt here--
and then setting
up load balancers.
This is all part of this--
I like to think of this
as your foundation,
so we're going to start
with this first lab
and this first quest.
Again, it's the
tip of the iceberg.
So we're going to create
a virtual machine.
Now I've finally caught up to
you all, playing along at home,
and we're going to actually
start the lab together.
So go ahead and
click on Start Lab.
Now one of the first
gotchas I'm going to say
is we're only going to be
doing part of this lab,
so I'm going to ask you to click
on, in the right hand side,
Create a New Instance
from the Cloud Console.
And that's going to jump
us down all the way here,
so if you're playing along I
want you to actually not start
at the very start of the lab.
You're going to be starting
from where the text says,
Create a New Instance
from the Cloud Console,
and we've got a little
bit over nine minutes
to see if Evan can't do this.
OK, so ultimately, we're
going to be having two tabs.
One is your lab
instructions, which
is what we're
looking at right now.
And the second, we actually
need to get to the Cloud.
So to get the Cloud, we need
to open the Cloud Console.
I'm just going to click on
this yellow button here,
and here's the second gotcha.
The first gotcha
is if you're not
starting in the same
place I am in the lab,
a lot of what I'm
going to be doing
is going to look very strange.
And the second
gotcha is when you're
prompted to sign in with
your Google Cloud account,
be sure you go back
to Qwiklabs and copy
the auto-generated username
that you see there.
I'm going to paste that in,
and again a lot of times
when we see these
Google sign ins,
we automatically type in-- if
you have your account already,
you might just type in
your personal account,
but that would defeat the
point of having this sandbox
environment.
Now your account's going
to be different than mine.
And once you're
taken to this screen,
you accept the terms of service.
Don't worry about setting
up any recovery options,
and once you've accepted the
additional terms of service
you should be taken
to a screen like this.
If you're taken to a screen
that says, Choose your Project,
and it has a
Qwiklabs-Resources and then
Qwiklabs-GCP and some
alphanumeric characters,
be sure that you're
on the Qwiklabs-GCP
with the alphanumeric
characters,
because that's your
automatically-generated Google
Cloud Platform account.
So you should already
give yourselves
a pat on the back, because
now you've actually accessed
the Google Cloud Platform.
So when you, or a
company, or your friends
are working in GCP, this is
what they say that they mean.
So you have a bunch of
different products and services
that you can open up on
the left side menu here,
and what we're going to be
focusing on today is spinning
up a virtual machine.
So go ahead and click
on Compute Engine,
and these are exactly following
the steps of the lab as well.
Now we have a bunch
of different options.
The default one is What
Instances of a Virtual Machine
Do We Have?
Go ahead and click
on Create, because we
don't have any so far.
That's going to prompt you with
a couple of different options.
There's a lot of
custom machine types,
and you can specify the zone
and the size of the CPU.
I mean, they go from one
virtual CPU to, I believe,
96 with over 100
gigabytes of RAM,
so you can get some pretty big
machine instances out there.
I'm just going to
type in a name.
You can feel free to
copy this as well--
GEC Lab.
And then the most important
thing, the third gotcha,
is since we're going
be creating a web
server we want folks to
access that server externally
through our IP address.
That's the foundation
of the internet,
and how the web works--
by allowing Hypertext
Transfer Protocol, or HTTP,
traffic allowed-- just that
first box and not both of them.
And go ahead and
click on Create.
All right, while that instance
itself gets spun up in this
particular zone-- it should only
take about a minute or two--
let's revisit the lab and
see what else we have left.
So a little over
six minutes-- let's
see if I can't get you guys on
a web server even ahead of time.
So scrolling down
in the lab you see
that we've set up the
virtual machine instance,
and now ultimately
what we want to do
is we need to get root
access to that web server.
And how you do that
is we're actually
going to ssh, or grant
ourselves access, into the VM,
and I'm going to copy this
first command onto my clipboard.
And I'm going to go back.
And if you see the good
news with the green check
right here, it means that
this instance is running,
so your VM is there for you.
Now the fourth gotcha is--
I've already disabled
it, but sometimes
when you click on
that ssh if you
have a browser where
it blocks your pop ups,
go ahead and disable that.
And then this
window will come up,
and this will be a terminal
into your own instance
that you just spun up
literally a minute ago.
So I mean compare
this to the past
again, so if you were buying
servers and putting them
in your garage, literally
the time to access the server
and install what you want
could be days, if not weeks,
to set everything up correctly.
And here, just in the span
of five to 10 minutes,
we now have a box
that we can access,
so I'm going to root
into the server.
So just paste in that command
or type it out, sudo su dash--
and we want to make sure
that the box has the latest--
by default, since
we didn't change it,
it's going be a Linux box.
So I'm going to see if
there's any Debian Linux
updates to the operating
system, so I'm just
going to copy the next
command here in the lab, which
is apt-get update.
So bring everything up to
date, and behind the scenes,
it's going to reach
out and see if there's
anything else that needs to
be updated on our operating
system.
And after it's done that,
this virtual machine
is ready for our use.
So now before we install
the NGINX web server,
I'm going to ask you to
copy this to your clipboard.
All you're doing is
apt-get install NGINX.
This is the really
important command.
It's just a one-line command
that installs a web server.
What I'd like you to do is
go back to Compute Engine.
Before you install
the web server,
click on this
external IP address.
Again, every web
site that's out there
has an external IP
address linked to it,
and it says that the
site can't be reached.
So if you have this page,
you're doing fantastic,
because ultimately we have not
installed the web server yet.
And NGINX is just an
open-source web server software
that will allow folks to
connect and through to your box.
And again, we're
installing a web server,
but if you want to run
things like Python scripts,
or do any kind of
processing-- anything
that you would want
to use a machine for,
you can use a
virtual machine for.
So let's get back
into our terminal.
We're going to install NGINX.
After that's done, it's
setting up all the tunnels.
While that's running, I'm going
to copy the last command, which
is making sure that the
NGINX process is running,
and we are very near
the finish line here.
So let's just see
if it's running.
Good, it's got master
processes for NGINX,
so crossing your fingers,
with just over three minutes
to spare, go into that tab
where you have that external IP
address already there.
And just for
showmanship, we're just
going to reload it in this tab.
So if you're taken
to Welcome to NGINX,
that's the default page
for your web server, that
means it successfully
installed, and you
can access it externally
through that IP address.
So congratulations if
you've gotten to this point.
If you're wondering how I
got to this IP address again,
go back into Compute Engine.
Click on External IP, and
that will bring you here.
So this is your blank
slate from a VM.
Let's recap.
You've created a
virtual machine.
And it can be of the
size of your choosing,
but by default we just went
with the default settings.
And with just a few lines
of the command terminal,
we've opened up a web
server, and now you've
accessed your VM
instance through the web.
So congratulations.
All right, so I'll pause
here and basically say,
even if your ultimate angle was
not to create a web server--
you wanted to run other
computational jobs,
you wanted to load
up applications,
you wanted to do batch
processing on your data--
anything that, as I
mentioned before, you
can use a machine
for, you can load up
into that virtual
machine instance.
Now the interesting
part about this is--
as you're going to learn as
you move through and through
the different labs
in the series--
there is still better
and better ways
of doing this type
of processing.
So maybe you're
thinking, well, Evan, I
don't want to root
access to a server,
and install operating
system software,
and then install-- anything
dealing with the terminal,
I really don't want to do.
Is there a way, or what
are the latest and greatest
technologies that
prevent me from having
to even touch the terminal?
And how do I manage multiple
instances of Compute Engine,
so I can just focus
on building software?
So if you're interested in
that type of technology,
and you're really hungry
to learn more about how,
for example, Kubernetes--
in one of the labs
you're going experience--
will actually orchestrate
and manage a lot of those VMs
for you behind the scenes--
then just let this be the
first part of your journey
into taking a lot of
those different labs.
So this is literally
just the start.
You've created your very first--
we have to start somewhere.
So you've created
your very first VM,
but that's just going to be
the first step that you're
going to take in this
particular quest.
All right, so I'm going to
close out of my terminal.
What I'll ask you to do
is-- when you're ready,
you can actually end that lab,
and I did it with a minute
to spare.
And please do rate the lab,
so if there's any issues
that-- you come across
them-- because our team
on the curriculum
development side
tries to do a good
job of creating
of all these exciting and
engaging labs for you all.
And speaking of all
the different options
that you have, to further
incentivize you all--
again, the world is there
for those who show up,
and obviously you are
doing an amazing first job
creating this virtual
first virtual machine here
at 9:00 AM Pacific.
So we wanted to reward you.
If, in the next
three or four days,
you complete the
rest of this lab--
since we only did part of it--
you want to complete the rest of
the Creating a Virtual Machine
Lab and the other six labs in
the quest for GCP Essentials,
then what we'll give you is an
additional $200 in GCP credit.
So for your own personal
account outside of Qwiklabs,
when you're ready to
actually do this for yourself
and create your own
GCP account, you'll
be credited an additional
$200 there to work with.
In addition-- honestly,
more valuable to that,
in my personal opinion,
is getting the experience
with things like, oh, I now know
how to create a virtual machine
instance.
And you get this
recognition of attendance,
and you win some pretty cool
badges as well and, dare I say,
bragging rights
for your friends.
So you can say, hey, I can
set up a VM in 10 minutes
or five minutes or less.
Can you?
As I like to say, this is
just the very first step
in your journey.
What we on the training
team here really want--
our ultimate end
goal is to get you
excited about using the Cloud.
And at the end of the day
if you're a machine learning
researcher, or a
data scientist--
or if you're someone that's
just looking to build a better
website, or build a better
mobile application, or a UI,
UX experience--
and you don't want to
worry about hardware.
You don't want to worry
about infrastructure,
or you want to rely on Google's
security for infrastructure
and hardware.
But you don't really
know where to start--
this is your best first step--
is to take these-- you already
have gotten familiarity
with what the Google
Cloud Platform looks like.
That's that blue dashboard that
we're looking at previously.
And then these trainings
go hand-in-hand,
so if you wanted to
take, for example--
oh, I'm curious to learn more
about deploying an application.
You can take the Deploying
Applications quest.
You've mastered GCP essentials.
You completed those seven labs.
Now you want to move on
to machine learning APIs.
You want to learn how to
translate different languages,
classify images--
if you want to learn about
orchestration of software
automatically behind the scenes,
you could take Kubernetes.
Again, this is--
I don't want to be
prescriptive in designating
what your learning
journey should take.
Just start with the foundation
as the essentials here,
and depending upon your business
and ultimately what interests
you, continue on
with the more quests.
And new content is added
here every single month,
and the labs are designed
to be interactive exactly
like the one you
experienced today.
All right, with that said, I'm
going to take a quick pause,
and all the questions
that you've been writing
and furiously want to get
answered we'll come back live,
and we'll choose the top
questions to answer live
for you in this webinar.
We'll be right back.
All right, well, I hope you
all enjoyed the live demo,
and you were able
to follow along.
Now, we have a couple of live
questions from the audience.
Number one, as you see here,
where do I log in to Quiklabs?
So the best place to just keep
this in the back of your mind--
Qwiklabs, you'll just have to
memorize the spelling of it.
It's google.qwiklabs--
Q-W-I-K-L-A-B-S.com.
If you go to
google.qwiklabs.com,
you'll see a massive
banner that says--
I'm looking at it here.
If you go there, it
says real-time training
in real environments,
and what you can do
is browse that
hands-on lab catalog.
Now the thing is, for
this webinar session,
be sure to use that Google
short link that we showed you
a little earlier, that hopefully
is still stored in the chat
below, because that's going to
give you those 20 free credits.
So if you try to log in
and sign in to Qwiklabs
through the normal route
that anybody else outside
of this webinar
will use, you won't
get those 20 free credits.
Often a question that
comes up as well--
if you've enrolled in
this quest previously,
and say you got halfway
through, and then
you attended this
webinar, and then
you try to-- you're
wondering like hey,
how do I get my 23 credits?
The best thing to do is
unenroll or de-enroll.
I'm not sure how to say it.
And then re-enroll,
and you'll get
those 20 free credits attributed
to your account as well.
And again, the big
honeypot at the end
is if you complete all
seven of those labs
in the GCP Essentials
Quest, the entire quest,
not only do you get an awesome
badge and you look really cool,
but you'll get that additional
$200 in GCP credits as well.
And you get about
four days to do that,
so if you enjoyed
that first lab just,
honestly, keep moving
right through them.
Question number two, I've never
used the Google Cloud Platform,
and I don't use
G Suite or GMail,
can I still take these labs.
Will I have to set
up a Google account?
Well, the great news about
Qwiklabs is you don't need to.
You can sign up to Qwiklabs
with any email address
that you have, and even if you
have a Google email address,
and you wanted to just use
a different email address,
you're more than welcome to.
Just sign up with whatever
email that you have,
and then once you actually
log in you might be asking,
well, hey, ultimately
am I not going
to use the Google
Cloud Platform?
Don't I need a Google
account for that?
And that's the super great
thing about Qwiklabs--
is it's our training platform,
so it will automatically
create these alphanumeric
usernames and passwords.
You'll get your own personalized
at Qwiklabs.net email
and that generated
password that you saw.
And that's what-- as you've
remembered from the demo--
I was copying and
pasting into the login.
And then that account is live
for the durations of your labs,
and then some of
these labs are short.
Like the basic ones
are 30 minutes,
and some of the
machine learning ones
that we just wrote
earlier this year
can take you upwards
of two to three hours
because they're
very, very advanced.
And they'll hold your
hand every step of the way
as you interact with not
just compute but five
or six different products in
the GCP Google Cloud Platform
project account.
Number three, I
enrolled in a quest
but still have zero credit.
What else do I have to do?
I think to answer that a
little bit with unenroll
yourself and then re-enroll
yourself, making sure to,
ultimately, use that
link, because when
you click on that link there
is special URL parameters that
actually get passed through.
Number five-- number
four, actually,
how do I get access
to these labs?
What does it cost?
So google.qwiklabs.com,
bookmark that URL,
and if you forget
that you can go
to a cloud.google.com/training.
And then all these labs will
be linked to there as well.
Then you can sign
in and sign up.
Some of the labs will start you,
so the initial labs are free.
But most of the labs will
actually call cost credits,
and to get these
credits what you can do
is you purchase them in--
you can purchase
them individually,
but there's also
a bulk discount.
So if you want to buy,
say, 1,000 lab credits
for your entire company,
there is a discounting in bulk
as well, and the pricing
is pretty transparent
when you get into the purchasing
or accessing the lab credits.
It'll prompt you
to get the credits
before you can take the lab.
That answers number five,
which has several of us--
the company want
to take the lab,
you can do a company account--
yeah, more than welcome to buy
in bulk and distribute as well.
Number six, if I know
the basics already--
I've spun up VMs.
I'm an expert at this already.
Do you have any advanced labs?
And yes we do.
Some of the labs--
honestly, even
though some of the labs I've
written myself last year,
I'll go back into them, and
I'm like, wait a minute.
At the end of the
day, I have to build
this, like,
machine-learning model that,
like, translates three
languages and, like,
classifies these images.
How on earth do
we do this again?
And the good news about
taking the labs again
is it'll take you all the
way from start to finish,
so even if it's a
super complex topic--
if I'm going throw scary
words at you like Kubernetes
or machine learning--
they're very, very accessible
when you partner with
the training and the labs
that we have
available to you here.
I'd highly encourage you.
I mean, I'm super biased because
I have created some of the data
in the machine learning
ones, but the ones
on application
development, monitoring
your security of
your applications,
there's over 100
labs, last I checked.
And a lot of them do
get pretty advanced,
but what I really would like
to leave you guys with is yes,
you can take the
labs individually.
But the quests are there almost
in like a linear fashion,
so you can go a la carte
and take a few labs.
I'm only interested
in Kubernetes.
I'm interested in more on Google
Cloud Storage-- and kind of log
manage your own
ad hoc curriculum,
but the quests, I would
say, organize those labs
in a prescriptive order to
make it a little bit more
easier for you to kind of
go through them linearly--
because the concepts
build on each other.
Lastly, what happens if
I get stuck doing a lab?
Where can I get help?
So this is a side
plug for Coursera.
A lot of our courses on our
online e-learning platform
for Coursera, you can go to
cloud.google.com/training,
and from there you can actually
access on-demand Coursera
courses which also feature
these same Qwiklabs labs.
And the benefit there
is you can actually,
when you get stuck
in a lab, Coursera
has a forum for each of
the different courses
that you take on there, and
then course creators like myself
and other Subject
Matter Experts, or SMEs,
monitor those forms
really, really actively.
And you can get the
benefit of students
that may have already
asked your question
or had an issue with
that lab in the past,
but at the end of the
day that's for more of a
I'm struggling
with the concept--
or this isn't really--
I want to ask more people
about how to better understand
what's going on.
If you're having any
technical issues whatsoever,
and regardless of whether
or not use Coursera or not,
the Qwiklabs support team
is absolutely amazing.
So inside of a lab,
if you ever run
into access issues or any
kind of strange things
where your account gets
deprovisioned for whatever
reason, in the lower
right hand corner
there is a button
that says Support.
And you can open up a ticket
with the support team,
and they're extremely
good about responding
in a really quick fashion.
So I guess those would
be the two things that I
would leave you as it is.
Take the trainings
where ever you see them.
Align yourself to a
track that interests you.
If you want a more
classroom type experience,
you can take the
Coursera courses,
or you can even register
for in-person courses, where
you can get an instructor
like me that will deliver it
in a physical location.
And last but not least,
if you have any issues
with the labs on
a technical level,
use that support
ticketing system as well.
Let's see.
Another question that
I will leave you with--
last bits of advice.
So before I lose
you guys, honestly,
getting the opportunity to come
up here and teach you even just
the basics of spinning
up a virtual machine,
it's not about the
tools or technology.
It's about the willingness and
the excitement that you all
have to tune in at
9:00 AM Pacific time
on a Tuesday morning to even
attempt something like this, so
like I said briefly in
the webinar earlier,
the world is there
for those who show up.
I myself didn't learn a lot of
these concepts from a textbook.
It's a lot of
on-the-job training.
So if you're in an
organization that is--
you can range the
spectrum of interested
in Cloud but unsure
of where to start,
or you're already using
Cloud and you're pretty
deep on the technical scale--
you're going to find these
trainings there for you.
And my only piece advices
is don't be afraid to fail.
So much like the best
machine-learning algorithms
are built upon many,
many, many thousands
of iterations of failure until
you find the one that works,
it's the same way with learning.
So the good news
about these labs,
there will always
be there for you.
And just honestly have a
blast and try to break them.
If you can find a lab with a
way that you would do it better,
submit a support ticket,
and then hopefully you'll
get a message from me saying,
hey, you did an awesome job
in correcting this, or
I love the direction
that you're taking it as well.
But, I mean, the last two
words that I'll leave you with
is just have fun with it.
The Cloud technology
is evolving,
and I'm sure five
years now, we're
going to be giving these
new webinars for you,
and the rest of the
webinars that you
take throughout the day
today and every Tuesday
here in February are
just going to give you
a taste of some of
the technology that's
out there here at Google for
you to use on Google Cloud
Platform.
But the space is
phenomenally growing,
and it's ever changing as well.
So keep yourself refreshed
of the latest updates that
are coming, and then more
importantly than that,
keep practicing with
these hands-on labs.
All right, well, that
does it for me here
in the studio in Mountain
View, California.
I want you to stay tuned for
your next session, which,
arguably, has an even more
exciting title than mine, which
is What is Love, Applying
Machine Learning to Help Win
the Hearts of Your Customers.
And you'll be going over
to the studio in Seattle.
See you guys later.